bonsoir messieurs bonsoir on sera
patrick bonnet d'abord cette
manifestation hier qu'est ce que
greenpeace amnistie internationale les
militaires autochtone prison reproche à
la rbc à la banque royale
en fait la banque royale est la
principale banque qui finance et qui
fait le montage financier du projet
costaud au gaz link le projet de gazoduc
qui traverserait leur territoire sans
leur consentement préalable libre et
éclairé et je voudrais c'est même les
nations unies qui en sont à leur
troisième lettre qu'elle les nations
unies ont adressé au canada pour dire
que ce projet doit arrêter il devrait
arrêter parce que le gouvernement n'est
pas allé chercher le consentement
préalable libre et éclairé également il
ya des violations actuellement très
inquiétante au niveau des droits humains
au niveau de la surveillance qui se fait
des arrestations forcé également je vous
dirais de la violence de la part de la
grc l'onu demande même que la grc
sortent du territoire et que le
gouvernement aille chercher justement ce
consentement préalable libre et éclairé
et le but entre autres de cette tournée
parce que le chef n'a mox à des watts ou
et n était au québec c'est justement de
faire comprendre aux investisseurs faire
comprendre aux décideurs et à la
population qui a de graves violations
des droits humains actuellement qui se
posent les ok la gare sausset territoire
et il faut que ça cesse éric tétreault
comment vous recevez ce discours bien il
faut d'abord dire que la grande majorité
des représentants du peuple et
souhaitait en incluant des élus s'est
prononcé pour le projet console gaz là
je suis bien désolé
je veux pas briser la logique
celui fait les opposants mais c'est un
fait allez sur google on stars vous
allez vous rend compte que toutes les
communautés web souhaitant sur le tracé
de ghost au gaz ling appuyé le projet je
suis allé moi-même en
colombie-britannique discuter avec elle
et avec eux ils se sont prononcés
clairement en faveur du projet c'est une
bonne affaire pour eux il se trouve
qu'il ya des représentants qui ne sont
pas d'accord comme dans n'importe quel
groupe de la société ce sont ses
représentants qu'on a entendu leur fait
pas plus grave que ça patrick bonnet
écoutez si c'est complètement fou ce que
dit monsieur tétreault il faut
comprendre que la cour suprême statue et
le groupe héréditaire au niveau de oued
souf bretonne n'ont jamais cédé leurs
droits n'ont jamais fait d'entendre son
souverain sur leur territoire ce qui a
été fait en fait il se pose c'est ces
clients-là s'opposent littéralement à ça
et lorsqu'on parle de leur territoire
ces vingt-deux mille kilomètres carrés
versus des réserves qui sont beaucoup
plus petites et oui une entreprise a
fait des ententes avec conseil de bande
qui était en passant évidemment création
du grand fédéral mais le consentement du
peuple et red star reconnue par la cour
suprême sur les vingt-deux mille
kilomètres carrés et en passant le
projet de gazoduc ne passe même pas sur
les réserves donc et alors ce n'est pas
vrai qu'il ya consentement il s'est
lui-même qui le dit je le répète c'est
pas greenpeace on le répète évidemment
mais je nuis l'abonné jusqu'où on va les
je vous parle de l' incendie des
voitures de michael fortier cette
semaine en fait il ya quelques jours je
me rappelais plus de la dette exactement
le vice-président du conseil de rbc
marchés des capitaux c'était au début du
mois voilà et qui a été revendiquée par
un groupe anonyme qui se dit animé par
la même solidarité que vous envers les
watts ou et haines et les opposants de
l'industrie extractive vous pensez quoi
de cette revendication
écoutez on est très claire évidemment
nous sommes greenpeace donc on a le mot
peace dans notre nom notre approche et
de la wii ont fait de la désobéissance
civile non violente
dans ce cas ci les chefs ont été très
clairs sur la manière de fonctionner des
oueds souhaitons c'est complètement non
violent le message est envoyé évidemment
à l'ensemble de ses membres et il n'y a
pas de violence de la part des watts ou
elton contrairement ce qu'on voit avec
la grc qui rentre avec descenza et dh
d'aller chercher de manière forcée les
membres des communautés les font
également t pour témoigner devant des
juges et ça c'est extrêmement
préoccupant et encore une fois amnistie
internationale est également très
préoccupé par ça donc il faut regarder
la violence coloniale actuellement de la
part de la grc sur le terrain et il a ce
problème là il pourrait être réglé
immédiatement en faisant en sorte en la
victoire alors je comprends ce que vous
dites patrick bonnet mais je vous
parlais de l' incendie
des véhicules du vice-président de la
rbc qui revendiqué par un groupe anonyme
par ailleurs contre les projets
d'oléoducs on a vu quand même beaucoup
de blocages de routes de voies ferrées
des occupations de sites également il ya
des gens qui ont connu des vedettes
comme mark ruffalo leonardo dicaprio qui
manifestent aussi aux côtés de
communauté autochtone et de communauté
environnementale le chantier aussi de
costauds kaeslin qui a été attaqué en
février et des roulottes qui ont été
détruites il ya une confrontation
violente vous l'évoquez patrick bonnet
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
détermination de la virulence également
que suscite ce débat ce conflit éric
tétreault bon d'abord une précision j'ai
bien dit que c'étaient les leaders élus
du peuple sont vingtaine qui se sont
prononcés que la cour suprême
reconnaissent une certaine autorité au
leader héréditaire je laisse aux avocats
l'idée c'est que les conseils de bar en
question du mans il lui supporte le
projet j'y suis allé moi-même ce que
j'en pense c'est très simple chaque fois
que mouvement société aujourd'hui votre
loin des gens santos cent des
solidarités tous scène que ça ça ça
commence en novembre dernier le 20
novembre car monsieur davidsuzuki a
évoqué qu'on allait peut-être faire
sauter d'été plein aussi les gens
n'écoutent pas entre parenthèses le
temps mais extinction rébellion à 17
nous entérinons ces propos là nous
sommes d'accord avec ça mais ça ça
s'appelle de l'incitation des violences
plus bas depuis ce temps d'aller des
gens qui gênent pas vous avez évoqué
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé sur les
chantiers costaud gathering mouche en
tant que les corps policiers sont très
très précis à trouver les coupables et
c'est bien dommage souvenez vous que
dans le projet énergie sacd et monsieur
fillion warren buffett et le go pass
hawaii avait spécifiquement mentionné
l'instabilité politique et le climat qui
régnait au canada lors de la crise
revient pour retirer ces 4 milliards du
projet et ça a été un facteur
déterminant dans l'abandon du projet
alors c'est ce qui arrive quand les gens
regardent ça existe je peux pas est ce
que vous dites qu'il ya une pression en
ce moment qui fait en sorte
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile de
faire ces projets-là de les financer
également
et que même les institutions financières
dont on parle
pourraient être tentés de cesser de
financer des projets comme des projets
d'énergies fossiles dans ce cas si éric
tétreault cet argent alors qui est qui
est détenue par des investisseurs
banquiers c'est davantage pour le moyen
long terme ce n'est pas nécessairement
pour le court terme il si le gardeur
axis c'est parce qu'ils apprennent
tranquillement faire confiance à
l'industrie aux moyens que l'industrie
elle-même va développer dans les
prochaines années grâce aux nouvelles
technologies pour faire notre effort et
on est conscient qu'on doit en faire un
très grand comme industrie pour
atteindre la carboneutralité ce sont des
objectifs qu'on partage bien sûr alors
ces gens nous font confiance à
l'industrie parce que lorsque le moment
viendra d'investir massivement par
exemple on en parlait la dernière fois
vous et moi me suffit lyon les projets
de captage et de stockage vient de
passer deux semaines encore là dedans
avec une délégation norvégienne ici au
québec et au canada n'a parlé que de ça
il faudra que les capitaux soit au
rendez vous et je pense que les grandes
banques comme la majorité des grands
investisseurs font preuve de sagesse en
ce moment et vous vous pensez patrick
bonin que ce n'est pas de la sagesse de
la part des institutions financières
qu'elles devraient carrément désinvestir
sortir de ces énergies fossiles
on n'est pas les seuls évidemment
regarder même la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec le deuxième plus
grand fonds de pension canadiens annoncé
que si la fin 2022 tout leur rôle tous
les pays seront retirés du secteur du
pétrole et il y a plein institutions qui
sont en train de bouger la banque
laurentienne annoncé qu'elle ne
financerait plus de nouveaux projets
pétroliers et gaziers l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie est très
claire on ne peut plus financer de
nouvelles infrastructures et je vous
ramènerai même au secrétaire général des
nations unies dans la foulée du rapport
du giec qui a très clairement dit que
les militants du climat sont parfois
dépeint comme étant des dangereux rhin
radicaux alors que les véritables
dangereux radicaux ce sont les pays qui
en manquent la production de
combustibles fossiles et qu'il est
moralement économiquement
c'est de la folie moral économique
d'investir dans les nouvelles
infrastructures pétrolières gazières et
électriques
je suis d'accord c'est précisément ce
qui arrive car des gens comme la caisse
de dépôt se départissent de leurs
accessoires un très grand joueur
d'ailleurs sont assez morale de caisse
de dépôt pardon davantage des blacks de
ce monde lorsqu'ils investissent lorsque
des investisse dans le pétrole qu'est ce
qui se passe ces actifs là son marché
sont vendus à bon prix sur un marché
secondaire ils sont repris par un
investisseur indien par un investisseur
chinois par un investisseur russe et
dieu sait qui et étant donné qu'ils
acquièrent à très faible coût ils sont
intéressés à maximiser les profits le
plus rapidement possible alors on a
davantage de pétrole et de gaz qui
inondent le marché à ce moment là aussi
une somme c'est un exercice à somme
nulle qui nous mène absolument nulle pa
le grand problème qui nous faut régler
en terminant qui on le fait ici ce soir
un peu et je tends la main encore une
fois il faut apprendre à faire confiance
à l'industrie comme étant un joueur
majeur pour régler cette crise
climatique c'est tout ce qui sème que
soit alors géant les gens ont vu la
réaction de patrick bonnet à 6 que vous
venez de dire on va s'arrêter là-dessus
patrick bonnet merci éric tétreault
également merci beaucoup merci à vous ce
soir on sort du journal tuoi pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit